I hate intros mode a douchey season one
disclaimer I don't know a lot about
Chinese culture and I psycho pronouncing
their names we come in 23 years before
the start of our story on a group of
cultivators who use magic to hunt evil
they come across a field of bodies and
their target / main character Wei Jing
also known as the Yi Ling patriarch he's
the founder of demonic cultivation so
when he dropped some flute beats all the
bodies come back to life and fight for
him he's killed by his junior Chong
Chong during the first stage of the
burial mounds way supposedly possessed
an unholy artifact the Stygian Tiger a
mule which he destroyed before he died
well let's jump ahead to the present at
mo village where Moceanu is performing a
ritual to offer his body to the dead
wait yang
sowait doesn't really have a choice and
is tossed into his body that gets kicked
around by spoiled brat we find out a
little bit more about Moceanu apparently
he is the bastard child of one of the
clan leaders and his mom died he's also
known for being a crazy lunatic the
ritual has a requirement fulfilling the
wish of the offer but wait doesn't know
what mo she on you wanted wait stands up
to the brat that was pushing him around
and puts him in his place and then
befriends a stubborn donkey who he
writes to town we aren't you do salon
Huan who was a cultivator that came
along with Longjing GE to meet with the
leader of mo village and the brats
mother they're being briefed on zombies
I've been ravaging the villagers and are
planning to lure them in and Slavin when
nighttime rolls around the brat his mom
and friend are all killed and zombified
by a demon arm this coincidentally
fulfills the requirements for the ritual
because Moceanu one of those three dead
does ami mom has a demon arm still
attached to her and is putting up a good
fight giving the cultivators a run for
their money which queues the
introduction of Long John or Wang ji in
the last scene yepez oh two ways seems
to know Wong ji from his past life and
doesn't want to run into him so he dips
with his donkey little apple which kind
of sounds like a failed rapper
well fleeing he runs into a net trap
that captures the donkey Jean Ling set
the trap and we find out that Moceanu is
a part of the gene cline where he makes
a comment about Jean Ling's mother not
teaching him to respect his elders which
sparks a fight it's not much of a fight
and Wei restrains him but then Ling jinx
uncle and the one who killed way in his
prior life John Chong shows up they
prepare to kill way because he was using
demonic cultivation but then Wan Jia
steps in to stop the fight
well she warns them that the demonic
left hand that killed three people in
town escaped into the mountains we also
learned that when Wei embraced the Dark
Arts in his past life Wang Zhi was this
arch enemy and was always trying to
catch him Wei recognizes Jean Ling sword
because in his past life he knew links
parents who were killed
that's why lien got so triggered when
Wei talked about his mother and makes
way regard what he said Lin yuan and
Jing Zhi end up going the same way while
looking for
the demon hand they are arguing since
they're from different clans and end up
getting into a fight while they're
fighting they end up in a cave and run
into the demon hand that possesses a
statue more cultivators show up to aid
in the fight while Wayde watches from a
distance Ling is trying to prove himself
to Chun by taking down the demon arm but
gets into a pinch so way it's forced to
bust out the flute beats I don't think
we want to know where he was keeping the
flute this whole time but he summons a
ghost general that helps in the fight
against the yarn the cultivators managed
to captured the demon arm so now they
set their sights on the ghost general
one Ning so--we orders wending to leave
what Chung still wants to kill way
because he was using demonic arts Wang
Zhi steps in and says that even though
he was using the demonic arts he was
helping them so he's gonna take him back
to LAN clan instead he episode 3 we jump
back 20 years to waste past life where
he's hanging out with the younger Jian
Chong there's a brief introduction did
Jean C chuan who was engaged to waste
senior and Chong's older sister after
that we mean yeah why sang and they both
go inside to find Wang Zhi sitting there
waiting for him wait I'd broken multiple
rules the night before when he tried to
sneak in alcohol and Wang she was there
and got into a fight with him later when
learning more about cultivation way
shows his first interest in harnessing
resentful energy but gets kicked out for
it we jump over to the one client
territory who drive out a mysterious
entity in the water but instead of
getting rid of it they push it further
downstream to gusu lime territory Wei is
caught helping why saying Chi in their
study so Wang Zhi is sent to keep an eye
on him he's under supervision for a
month where he continuously trolls Wang
Zhi in the last scene the water and Eddy
shows up in gusu LAN territory and a
fisherman witnesses it along with a
bunch of corpses the episode four-way
and Chong tagged along to a goose ooh
LAN town for the exorcism of water
ghouls and we get introduced to LAN WAN
while chatting up some of the locals we
accidentally runs his boat into Jean Z
she wants C she want is kind of a
pompous tution and soul so Jian family
even though he's still engaged to chunk
sister this causes some tension with way
but before if I can break out they are
attacked by water ghouls
this water goal is just going for it the
cultivators deal with the ghouls and
then head to a lake that could be the
source of the resentful energy they end
up running into a water borne abyss
which is way out of their league so they
have to prioritize saving lives and for
treating ways pulled into the water and
is surrounded by the resemble energy he
thinks about how he could control it but
he gets pulled to safety before he can
the cultivators come to the conclusion
that the one clan is probably the ones
responsible and sent the abyss down the
one clan has many allies and are very
powerful so they try to figure out how
to hold them accountable because
denouncing them won't do any good
episode 5 wait Scott again by Wang ji
trying to sneak in alcohol but this time
he tackles Wang ji so they're both out
grounds past curfew they both get beaten
for breaking the rule
so they go to a spring to help the
injuries heal while at the spring
several zombies that were being held
captive get free so they both go to help
around him up Wang Zhi gets a source on
a guitar and handle some of them but Wei
got separated from him and is running
four more zombies what if the zombies
almost kill sway but he manages to stop
the attack I think his goal de corte was
resisting the resentful energy I'm not
entirely sure but the zombie starts to
ignore Chung shows up and sees that he's
being corrupted while fighting the
zombies he scolds way for taking a hare
takes bath and says that the cultivators
are gonna kill him in response to this
way promises that he's never gonna do it
again
yep the sowed six Jiwon is back at it
and being confrontational again talking
badly about a soon-to-be-wife he that
makes a remark about Chong's Father
treating way better than Chung even
though Chung is his real son ways
impulsive as always so he gets into a
fight with him this is the last dropper
way so Chung father and the head of the
clan Zhang Feng Mian has to come and
bail him out Wei was supposed to be
studying there for a year but isn't
welcome there anymore so he's taken back
home once there we're introduced as jung
yong li which is the girl that way was
white knighting and Chong's older sister
she seems really soft-spoken and nice
unlike long Islands wife using yuan who
appears to be really cold and spiteful
g'wan shows that she's not exactly a fan
of boy
luckily Yan Li is there to calm her down
and defend him later we find out that
the marriage between Yan Li and zhi xuan
was called off because they don't have
feelings for each other Joo Won is
pissed at the decision and blames away
for the outcome way goes to apologize to
Yan Li about running her engagement but
she seems okay with it because she
didn't love Z she want now we jump ahead
one year to when Sean comes back from
studying with the GU Ceylon clan in the
last scene way and Chong are talking
about a discussion conference being held
in the one client's nightless city he
episode 7 on his way to the nightless
city way runs into wedding ink who was
practicing his archery and is really
good side no wedding is the infamous
ghost general that he summons an episode
3 to fight the demon arm once in the
city he gets to see Wang Zhi again who
still hates him we get introduced to
some more of the clan leaders as all of
them are gathered there to eat and drink
together we have Mia means away who is
tilted because the one clan had set up
the seating so that it looks like
they're the leaders of the cultivation
clans he is talked down by lon cheetah
and who points out that near Ming Shui
has been wanting to take vengeance on
the one clan because of his father for
years another one of the leaders is Jean
Guang Shan who is also trying to calm
him down the second master of the wine
clan when Chou makes his entrance and he
clearly looks like an antagonist and
finally we have the one clan leader when
Ruo Han who joins them to kick off the
meal while the leaders e an archery
competition is held hunting ghosts for
their entertainment each clan sends
representatives into the arena and
whoever gets the most kills wins when
isn't allowed to go in because he has
distant lineage but way stands up for
him saying that he has a good shot they
asked one need to demonstrate but he
chokes hard so yes I set this one out
during the competition when members
tried cheating and get called out for it
so they shoot arrows at the guy calling
them out Wang ji is forced to step in to
prevent the guy from being killed after
that way tries fixing Wong G's headband
which is apparently a big no-no for LAN
members so Wong she gets tilted and
leaves the event Yepez O'Day Ruo Han
thinks that the other clans are getting
arrogant and need to be taught a lesson
the wine clan launches a campaign
annexing dozens of clans and whoever
they felt was annoyed out the cloud
recesses in the gusu LAN territory we're
way and Chong had gone to study was
burned down during the attack the gusu
blonde leader was badly injured and his
oldest son launched e10 was gone but
worst of all won't she's worth out to
Qatar broke you can do whatever you went
to the city but the man shreds why would
you mess with his dreams after that the
blank land amantha each clan send them
disciples which are basically just held
hostage when they arrive they are
greeted by one Chao and the gold digger
Wain ling Jie Zhao the disciples are
asked to hand over their swords when
refused when juju uses his ability to
melt away one of the disciples golden
cores later on when they're being forced
to work we find out that Wang G's leg
was broken trying to prevent the library
from being burnt down after that the
disciples are forced to hunt for a
monster in a cave the gold digger wants
to use a girl that she's jealous of his
bait so soldiers are ordered to tie her
up and make her bleed the girl hides
behind Wang Zhi who ends up defending
her in response to this the soldiers are
ordered to kill the disciples and while
fighting the giant tortoise that they
were there to hunt shows up episode 9
wen Shan is men flee from the Cape to
avoid the monster and destroy the exits
trapping the disciples inside they think
there could be another exit somewhere in
the water that they can use to escape so
they start looking for one John finds
where they can pass through so everybody
prepares to leave while way distracts a
monster with the flame formation what's
the point formation wears off the
monster focuses on trying to kill way
giving the others a chance to escape
after they get outside when soldiers are
waiting and fire a volley of arrows at
them leaving Chun as the only survivor
back in the cave Wang jihad stay behind
to help away escape he gets bitten and
nearly killed by the monster so they
have to fall back in way helps treat
wong g's injuries long gee thanks him
which was the first time he said
anything that's the way so now what
choice do I have I have to ship them
sorry way on LI you've been shipwrecked
by those beaming gold eyes they figure
they have to kill the monster to escape
so they start plotting on how to go
about doing that
meanwhile the sole survivor Chun is on
his way home to get help Wei acts as
bait to go when lure the monster out and
find some sort of corrupted sword in the
monster when he grabs the sword all the
resemble energy that was built up starts
flowing into his golden core now it's
his turn denier they get eaten
1g saves his life by decapitating the
monster yep the so tenth with the
monster dead Wang ji starts flexing his
musical talents they end up staying in
the cave for seven days before Chung
could get to them and bring way back
home I think we all know what happened
after that sweet serenade that Wang Shi
put on seven days with those eyes are
you kidding me something happened
meanwhile Chao had taken credit for
killing The Tortoise we also learned
that Wang G's father had died from his
injuries
do you want in Fang meal and get into
another fight because you want things
say he's favoring way over Chung she
claims that he dislikes Chung because he
doesn't like her and he can't really
blame him on that one there are also
rumors going around that he still has
feelings for ways mom and that way is
actually his son even though there's no
proof that this is actually the case the
one clan send their loyal prospector
over to order that way be punished since
long me on his Ganzi you want is acting
in his place so she whips away after
that the prospector commands that she
cuts off his hand and also says that the
Lotus pier will be working for the wind
clan as a supervisory office turns out
that's not gonna fly and z-one slaps her
and then combos into a backhand making
this the most satisfying scene of the
show so far episode 11
Yuya comes to the prospectors a Tang
goes one of you one of those you want
then he just walks out with the
prospector while way and chunks sit
there like get in there man what are you
guys doing that was your contribution
you stop them Joe's waiting outside of
Lotus pier with the fleet and gets the
signal from gold-digger to launch the
attack a defensive barriers race to
block the incoming attacks from the when
soldiers bazooey you're disabled say gee
if only somebody had dealt with that guy
bugging me on his on a ship and sees the
glow of the shield in the distance so he
takes some men to go help defend it
Jiwon sends way and Cheung away on a
boat while giving Chun her lightning
rings idiot the ring keeps them bound
for a duration but when they get free
they go back to find Z you want and Fang
Mian were both killed Cheung blames way
for their deaths because way helped
along G defend the girl in the caves the
episode 12 waiting chunker and hiding
and trying to make their way to Yan Li
who was on a trip when the attack
happened
Wang Zhi and his uncle chetan both agree
that they need to find a way to unite
the clans against the winds way goes to
look for food and Chung leaves to go
back to Lotus pier
Wei has to go looking for him and finds
him in bad condition being held by the
winds he's trying to escape with him
when Ning the Archer that he vouched for
at the competition gives them a place to
hide
big sister comes in and finds him she's
a doctor and decides to help them so
Chung doesn't die when Chun wakes up he
tells wait that during the fighting Zhu
Li who had destroyed his golden core so
we can't use cultivation anymore Wei
tells him that he remembers Bao Shan Sun
Ren who was his mother's master he tells
Chong the Sun Run will be able to bring
his golden core back no problem so
they're gonna go look for him episode 13
waiting she'll make it to the mountain
where it's on run lips so naturally the
next step is to send Chong got the
mountain boy
folded by himself he's just chillin at
the bottom of the mountain waiting for
him to return
Julius sneaks up on him he tries the
male to score and then Chow stabs him
they take away with them and throw him
into the yielding burial mounds which is
swarming with resentful energy jump over
to Wang Zhi who runs into his older
brother Shi Chen who was still missing
after the winds attacked Claude recesses
a meeting is held with the leaders of
the clans to try to convince him to join
together and fight against the winds
Zhang makes his reappearance at the
meeting to do his part in rallying the
clients together they're hesitant at
first but she Qin reveals that while he
was gone he had rallied an army from the
men who were victims to the one clan
this is enough to convince the other
clans and they become allies launching
the SunShot campaign now we're gonna hop
on back over the way who was being
consumed by the resentful energy and
having hallucinations of his life
episode 14 the start of the SunShot
campaign wasn't looking so good but then
D mu a wins a decisive victory and kills
rural Hans oldest son when she'll
improving morale meanwhile word is
getting around at the supervisory
offices that the ones had set up are
being attacked by feral ghosts when G
finds talismans in the battlefield that
summon evil which has never been seen
before John gets reunited with his
sister and tells her that way is still
missing a when Scout fights the Jian
clans hat out so chat watches an attack
on that but on prospector doesn't want
to go to the battles so she stays behind
and is killed by waste flute skills Chau
had won the battle against Wang Zhi and
Chong but way makes an ominous entrance
as they're getting cornered in the last
scene episode 15 way uses all of the
dead bodies to kill the wind soldiers
until it's just Chow and zoo vu alive he
targets uu view first taking his golden
core and smashing it and then some
zombie bros eat him after that he
targets Chau using the resemble digger
to mess him up and then finishes him off
by impaling him on a huge resentful
spike after that they take back load a
spear while discussing the fact that
Rohan has said 10,000 cultivators who
attack their borders to deal with this
way wants to retrieve the sword that was
in the tortoise cave because of all the
resentful energy it possessed we jump
back to the present where Wang Chi and
his older brother Shi Jin are talking
about the fact that the demon arm was
tossed into mo village by somebody with
malicious intent
Wei overhears cultivators talking about
the Stygian Tiger and seems like he
really regrets making it in the last
scene when Wang Zhi are gazing into each
other's eyes I'm gonna go ahead and
assume that they're thinking about those
glorious seven days and after watching
the scene I came to the conclusion that
the only thing I hate more than intros
is outros